[Musique]
on attend un plan savoir où on va et de
quelle manière on va c'est cela que les
français attendent du président de la
république je crois que en ces temps de
complotisme il est important que la
parole du président de la république
soit une parole claire et en vérité je
souhaite simplement qu'ils nous disent
où est ce qu'ils veulent aller parce que
c'est ça le problème c'est qu'on a
objectivement le sentiment que le cap
n'est pas très précis une fois qu'on
saura où ils veulent conduire notre pays
alors on dira ce que nous en pensons
mais on peut pas laisser cette période
d'incertitude aussi vaste tant qu'on n'y
en a pas complètement sécurisé la
situation à l'intérieur de schengen il
ya la nécessité
bien évidemment la fermeture des
frontières extérieures et intérêts le
contrôle aux frontières me semble
essentiel je trouve d'ailleurs on
l'avait dit qu'il a trop tardé à être
mis en place en france
ce qu' il y a eu un manque
d'anticipation il ya eu des débuts qui
ont été chaotiques et souvent même
cacophonie coup ce même du gouvernement
ce que j'aimerais enfin ce que j'attends
aussi c'est que le président de la
république laisse les collectivités
quand elles sont des solutions pouvoir
s'exprimer aujourd'hui qu'elle ne soit
pas là pour les brider la situation
actuelle démontre la faillite de l'état
je ne cible pas le gouvernement en
particulier mais au fond pourquoi les
maires prennent ces initiatives parce
que les mères sont au contact direct du
terrain et qu'ils n'ont pas l'habitude
de rester spectateur de la situation
cette affaire du masque restera dans
cette crise comme le symbole d'une
mauvaise gestion en tout cas d'une
gestion de la crise qui aurait été
inspiré non pas par les bonnes pratiques
mais simplement par la gestion de la
pénurie on voit que s'il n'y a pas les
collectivités pour pallier aux
manquements de l'état
eh bien nous ne serions pas capables de
faire face à cette crise dans des
conditions que nous connaissons je pense
qu'il faut être très unie dans dans la
poursuite d'un seul et unique objectif
qui est celui de sortir de cette douce
et crise de sortir du confinement de
sortir de cette menace sur la santé
de chaque de chacun est évidemment de
sortir très très vite de l'enlisement
l'économique du confinement économique
de la récession est connu pour remettre
en activité il y à une anticipation très
importante dans les différents secteurs
d'activité par exemple entre l'industrie
lourde
les travaux publics le secteur tertiaire
comment peut se remettre en activité
quelles vont être les gestes barrière
quelles sont les règles qu'il va falloir
adopter
et ça c'est un travail qui doit se faire
avec les fédérations professionnelles
avec les partenaires sociaux
et c'est le rôle de l'état et c'est ça
que le président de la république doit
décliner au delà des gestes médiatique
on n'est plus dans les gestes médiatique
il y aura apporté un certain nombre de
réponses à caractère économique sociale
sociétale
[Musique]